COVID VACCINE.
WATCH THIS.
>> MY PERSONAL CHOICE TO TAKE A
MORAL STAND FOR MEDICAL FREEDOM
AND PERSONAL CHOICE.
I WILL BE SIGNING OUT OF
SERVICE FOR THE LAST TIME TODAY.
PLEASE, PLEASE, PLEASE TAKE
CARE OF EACH OTHER.
MAKE SURE YOU ALL GO HOME AT
THE END OF EACH DAY.
>> MY FINAL SIGN-OFF AFTER 22
YEARS OF SERVING THE
CONSTITUENT SENSE OF THE STATE
-- -- CITIZENS FOR THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON
I'M LEAVING.
JAY INSLEE CAN KISS MY --
>> Harris: YOUR REACTION TO
THAT, JASON RANTZ.
>> IN THE CASE OF THE LATTER
VIDEO YOU PLAYED THE TROOPER
HAS BEEN ON MY SHOW FOR SEVERAL
TIMES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS AND I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
CLOSELY HIS STRUGGLE HERE.
THESE ARE TWO PEOPLE IN THIS
CASE WHO ARE DEEPLY RELIGIOUS
AND HAVE RELIGIOUS CONVICTIONS
AGAINST THIS PARTICULAR VACCINE
AND ALSO AS YOU HEARD DOING IT
FOR THE SAKE OF PERSONAL
FREEDOMS AND MEDICAL CHOICE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT NOT JUST THE
TROOPERS BUT ANY OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO ARE
IMPACTED BY THIS MANDATE, MANY
OF THEM HAVE TOLD ME PRIVATELY
I'M VACCINATED BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT OF
GOVERNMENT TO REQUIRE THIS AS A
CONDITION OF EMPLOYMENT.
THAT'S WHAT WE ARE STARTING TO
SEE A LOT OF.
THIS BELIEF THAT EVERYONE
PUSHING BACK IS UNVACCINATED.
THAT IS NOT TRUE.
>> Harris: THAT'S FASCINATING
AND THAT'S WHY I WAS MAKING THE
POINT ABOUT THEY JUST WANT TO
KNOW ARE YOU OR ARE YOU NOT.
BUT THEN JASON I WONDER IF
SOMETHING ELSE ISN'T AT PLAY.
WHEN I FIND OUT IN CHICAGO THAT
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO FOOT THE
BILL FOR THE TESTING AFTER
MANDATING THAT YOU GO GET
SOMETHING ELSE, A VACCINE, BUT
THEY AREN'T GOING TO OFFER YOU,
IT FEELS LIKE THEY'RE
NEGOTIATING IN BAD FAITH AND
THEN THEY WON'T GIVE YOU THE
TIME TO GET THE TESTING.
FEELS LIKE THEY'RE NEGOTIATING
IN BAD FAITH.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
SOME TAX DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THAT?
IT BLOWS MY MIND.
>> THEY CLEARLY HAVE THE MONEY
TO DO THAT.
IN SEATTLE, FOR EXAMPLE, THERE
IS NO TESTING OPTION.
YOU EITHER GET VACCINATED OR
YOU WILL BE FIRED.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
YOU AREN'T EVEN GIVEN THE
OPTION IN SOME OF THESE CASES.
WE WERE TOLD OVER THE LAST 18
MONTHS THAT ALL OF THESE FOLKS
WERE HEROES, FRONT LINE WORKERS
ESSENTIALLY AND THEY ARE
PROTECTING US AND DOING SO AT
GREAT RISK TO THEMSELVES.
NOW LAST YEAR AT THIS EXACT
TIME THERE WAS ZERO PERCENT
VACCINATION.
RIGHT NOW IN SEATTLE AND
WASHINGTON IN GENERAL THERE ARE
80% OF THE STATE VACCINATED
WITH AT LEAST ONE SHOT.
THEY ARE TELLING US BACK THEN
IT WAS SAFER THAN IT IS NOW FOR
THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
TO DO THEIR JOBS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IT IS NOT LIKE AFTER THEY GET
VACCINATED THEY LOSE ALL THE
PPE THEY'VE BEEN WEARING.
THEY STILL HAVE TO WEAR THAT.
NOTHING HAS EFFECTIVELY CHANGED
IN THAT REGARD.
>> Harris: SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE PERCENTAGES, THE
NUMBERS OF OFFICERS WHO DIED OF
COVID IN THE COUNTRY, THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT JUST IN TERMS OF
SAFETY HERE.
BUT THAT HASN'T PERSISTED
NECESSARILY AS HIGH AS IT WAS
AT ONE POINT.
ARE MAYBE MORE GETTING NATURAL
IMMUNITY?
YOU KNOW OFFICERS WHO ARE
VACCINATED AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> EXACTLY.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO PAY ATTENTION TO.
IT IS TRUE THERE HAVE BEEN
OFFICERS WHO DIED FROM COVID.
NOT NECESSARILY COVID THEY
CAUGHT ON THE JOB, WHICH I
THINK IS AN IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION HERE.
PLENTY OF STUDIES INCLUDING
HERE IN WASHINGTON THAT SHOW
EMS RESPONDERS TO EMERGENCIES
WHO WERE DEALING WITH PEOPLE
WHO IN SOME CASES YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO EVEN WEAR
YOUR OWN MASK DEPENDING WHAT
YOU ARE DOING WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL SHOWED A VERY
LITTLE, IF NOT INSIGNIFICANT,
AMOUNT OF TRANSMISSION OF COVID
BETWEEN PATIENT AND EMS
PROVIDER AND VICE VERSA.
WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE.
IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS OF
OFFICERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BEING PUT OUT OF A JOB, THERE
ARE SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPLICATIONS.
>> Harris: MORE THAN 300
SEATTLE POLICE OFFICERS HAVE
RETIRED OR QUIT IN THE PAST
YEAR AND CITING ANTI-POLICE
SENTIMENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND IT COMES AS SHOOTING
INCIDENTS HAVE SPIKED BY 39%
FROM THE SAME PERIOD LAST YEAR.
YOU ALREADY HAD A CALDRON AND
NOW JUST MORE FLAME AND
GASOLINE ON THAT.
>> YEAH.
WE'RE IN TERRITORY WE HAVEN'T
BEEN SINCE THE 80s AS HOW MANY
DEPLOYABLE OFFICERS WE HAVE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE AT A STAGE 3
MOBILIZATION EFFORT FOR THE
SEATTLE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
ANYONE WHO IS DEPLOYABLE IS
UNIFORM READY.
IF WE NEED TO RESPOND TO 911
CALLS THE DETECTIVE WHO MAY TRY
TO SOLVE A MURDER CASE WILL END
UP RESPONDING TO 911 CALLS.
TODAY WE EXPECT POTENTIALLY
DEPENDING ON WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING WITH THE FINAL
NUMBERS WHEN THEY GET REPORTED
WE EXPECT 60 OR 70 OFFICERS WHO
WILL NOT HAVE SUBMITTED THEIR
PAPERWORK AND WHO WILL BE
UNEMPLOYED SHORTLY AT A TIME
WHEN I SPOKE TO THE POLICE
CHIEF A COUPLE WEEKS AGO SAID
WE NEED AS MANY PEOPLE HIRED AS
POSSIBLE RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE 500 OR SO SHORT OF WHAT
WE NEED TO BE.
>> Harris: UNBELIEVABLE.
QUICKLY THE POLITICS OF THIS.
DEMOCRAT MAYOR CHICAGO, LORI
LIGHTFOOT.
DO THESE LEADERS REALIZE THAT
THEY ARE LEAVING THEIR THEIR
OWN PUBLIC IN A CORNER WITH NO
ONE TO PROTECT THEM FROM BEING
CORNERED?
IF SOMETHING HAPPENS TO YOU IN
THE CITY OF CHICAGO OR SEATTLE
AFTER PEOPLE LEAVE THEIR JOBS
OVER THE FIGHT WITH THESE CITY
COUNCILS AND MAYORS, I THOUGHT
THEIR NUMBER ONE JOB WAS PUBLIC
SAFETY.
HOW DO THEY STAY IN OFFICE?
>> THESE ARE CITIES THAT ARE
RUN BY FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
PUSHING DEFUND POLICING.
LORI LIGHTFOOT HAS WALKED IT
BACK SIGNIFICANTLY AND THE
MAYOR IN SEATTLE HAS WALKED IT
BACK SOME BUT COUNCIL MEMBERS
ARE LEANING INTO DEFUNDING.
WHAT A BETTER WAY TO DEFUND
POLICE TO QUIT ON THEIR OWN AND
SAY THEY WERE SELFISH AND
DIDN'T WANT TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC FROM COVID.
80% OF THE BUDGET FOR THE
SEATTLE POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
PERSONNEL.
SO YOU LOSE A FEW OF THOSE
OFFICERS YOU GET CLOSER TO THE
50% DEFUNDING THAT THEY
PROMISED.
>> Harris: THEN THEY TRICK THEM
BY EITHER MAKING THE TESTING
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE ON THEIR
SHIFT AND NOT PAY FOR OR LIKE
IN YOUR CITY DON'T GIVE THEM AN
ALTERNATIVE AT ALL.
THIS WAY OR THE HIGHWAY.
IT IS A TRICK.
IT IS NOT HONEST NEGOTIATIO